c'est la défense des exclus de la
société que prend en main rené lenoir
secrétaire d'état aux affaires sociales
il annonce un effort accru d'action
sociale les crédits globaux affectés à
l'aide sociale seront pour 1975 de 12
milliards et demi contre 10 milliards en
parmi les projets de lois les plus
importants celui en faveur des
handicapés
il concerne deux millions de personnes
la loi prévoit une modernisation des
prises en charge pour les mineurs une
allocation d'éducation spéciale d'au
moins 230 francs prise en charge à 100 %
pour les enfants placées en
établissement pour les adultes un
minimum garanti de 600 francs un salaire
égal au smic pour ceux qui peuvent
travailler en milieu normal 90 % du smic
pour ceux qui travaillent en milieu
protégé 60 à 70 % pour ceux qui
travaillent en centre d aide par le
travail des aides seront accordées aux
employeurs publics ou privés qui
offriront des emplois autre projet de
loi pour une coordination des
institutions sociales publiques ou
privées en vue d'une plus grande
efficacité
certains établissements sociaux créés
par des collectivités pourront obtenir
des subventions dans un délai de 5 ans
tous les hospices se transformeront en
maison de retraite médicalisée pour
soigner les personnes âgées invalides
un autre projet de loi concerne les
inadaptés sociaux les centres
d'hébergement auront désormais un champ
d'action élargi
ils deviendront de véritables centres de
réadaptation sociale pour l'accueil des
personnes en difficulté sans logement ni
ressources ils ont trouvé un vrai un
long séjour en hôpital dans la descente
ils reçoivent encore des drogués des
libérés de prison des vagabonds des
femmes en rupture conjugale dans ces
centres pilotes
les maires peuvent être accueillis avec
leurs enfants après un séjour plus ou
moins longs pacifié rééquilibrer elles
parviennent grâce aux services sociaux à
trouver un emploi et un logement
mon mari a eu un grave accident de
voiture donc je me suis retrouvé sans
ressources sans logement attend un bébé
est déjà un enfant de deux ans et demi
grâce à ce centre j'ai pu retrouver un
peu de tranquillité avant mais encore
une marge à personne est vraiment
l'accueil que j'ai eues ici m'a permis
de reprendre goût à la vie 70 à 80 mille
personnes transitent chaque année dans
les trois centres existants un rythme de
passage de deux mois de nouveaux centres
doivent être créés un effort d'action
sociale qui mène à plus de justice